ça bouge dans le monde de la musique en
continu après le lancement d'apollo
lieuse et qu'au mois de juin
la faillite du service radio cet automne
c'est maintenant au tour de google
d'annoncer une stratégie compétitive
pour faire le plein d'abonnés c'est à
dire que google va rendre son service
google music gratuit ou sur mathieu ça
existe et les jeunes groupes les
musiques mais il fallait payer pour
avoir un c'est donc on veut élargir le
nombre d'abonnés donc on rompt ce
gratuit il ya une contrepartie
ça veut dire qu'il y aura des pubs qui
seront affichés sous forme de bannières
ou entre les chansons jusqu'à six
publicités à l'heure ça occasionne aussi
cette annonce de la fermeture du système
sanguin a donc le réseau songs that de
musique en continu qui avait été acquis
par google l'an dernier c'était quand
même 3 millions d'abonnés au canada dont
environ 600 milles au québec ça va
fermer et tous ces gens là vont migrer
vers la grande famille globaux mais
google a été déjà dans la musique on
continue avec youtube youtube raid qui
est un donc un service de youtube sans
publicité ces 10 dollars par mois
ça fonctionne très bien actuellement
l'application est vraiment dans les tops
de vente aux états unis mais faut dire
aussi que youtube raid les gens qui sont
déjà abonnés parce que c'est aussi ça
appartient à google
ils auront deux fils l'abonnement à
google prix newzik d'alors mais c'est un
marché qui est quand même déjà assez
encombré nom très encombré avec une
difficulté de convertir des abonnés
gratuit en abonnés payants regarder on a
par exemple les deux dans le monde qui
est pandora 78 millions d'abonnés
gratuit seulement 4 millions d'abonnés
payants
spotify 75 millions d'abonnés dont 20
millions payant et à pour muse et 15
millions avec un taux quand même assez
élevé 6.5 millions d'abonnés payants et
sa baisse a des répercussions aussi sur
les redevances qui sont payés aux
artistes parce qu'actuellement c'est
presque rien
oui c'est ça mais ça c'est un gros gros
problème ces redevances et un très gros
problème
un exemple écouter cette chanson
et parmi les états en 2014 sortant
d'europe u 43 millions d' écoute de
cette chanson là ça lui a rapporté 3500
$ pour lui c'est du changement dans
l'entrée et donc sa règle pas la
question le fait qu'on a un nouvel
acteur là dessus ni redevance qui sont
versés aux artistes actuellement c'est
risible les artistes dont vous le dire
et ça peut avoir des impacts majeurs sur
l'industrie de la musique au canada et
ce sera à suivre parce que cette
question là
malgré l'arrivée d'un nouveau joueur
elle n'est pas encore réglé tout reste
ouvert merci beaucoup m l'usure